[Musique]
l'assemblée générale du mouvement
indépendantiste martiniquais la date
arrive très vite elle est prévu le 16
janvier prochain après celle avortée du
7 septembre dernier bonjour lionel des
roses bonjour monsieur viol dont il est
le trésorier du mime du mime tendance
alfred marie-jeanne il faut le préciser
colistier de ce dernier puisque deux
listes sont en lice pour le
renouvellement du conseil
d'administration du mime lors de cet âge
à venir lionel des roses votre camp et
vos adversaires avaient manifesté une
incompréhension après la publication du
cabinet me what dans le france antilles
pour convoquer cette assemblée générale
est ce qu'aujourd'hui
à quelques jours de cette ag est ce que
vos doutes vos incompréhension vos
colères peut-être ont été dissipés si
vous permettez monsieur le temps puis
remettez vous permettez moi de
m'adresser aux martiniquais de le
soutien d'une bonne année 2010 9 de les
inviter à se mettre au travail à tous
les niveaux et lui non élus toutes les
chacun chaque martiniquais se mettent au
travail pour que les souhaits que nous
imitons se réalise que la martinique eux
vivent de milieu joue dans cette année
2019 soit interdite alors dans la
présentation
lionel des roses trésorier du mini
tendance alfred marie-jeanne doubler
leur aide faut bien préciser qu'il ya
deux listes
il faudrait peut-être commencer par
faire l'historique 74
le parti politique même le mouvement
indépendantiste matinée du martiniquais
voit le jour 1974 en 2004 après que
alfred marie-jeanne soit élu député
les dirigeants du mime estime qu'il y a
lieu de bénéficier de l'aide publique
comme le font les autres partis
politiques
et c'est là que cdc dirigeants décident
de créer une association de gestion pour
bénéficier des aides publiques à ce
moment là alfred marie-jeanne avec à ses
côtés jean philippe miller et sylvain
boli noir
créé cette association avec d'autres
membres et les premiers et les premiers
élus du conseil d'administration sont à
fred marjane sylvain ballin roy et jean
philippe denis law et aujourd'hui il
faut bien faire la distinction entre ce
parti politique et cette association qui
malheureusement au du est une
association de gestion mais qui est tout
simplement une association qui
aujourd'hui on se pose la question
est-ce que dès la création ce coup
d'état n'avait pas été organisée enfin
c'est à vous de voir c'est entre vous
mais est ce que le ce matin les doutes
sont dissipés les et compréhension suite
à la publication de la noce du cabinet
me what je vous réponde je vous repose
la question alors la première chose
nous avons su une communication de notre
conseiller à soi qui nous informe que
l'assemblée générale ait repoussé au 30
c'est pour vous dire comment il ya
encore des flous comme le cabinet me
wade c'est la formation du jour toi y
aura pas d'assemblée générale le 16 il
voit pas d'assemblée générale le 16
j'ai un reçu par mail un document de m
edmond mariette venant du cabinet me
what disant que l'assemblée générale ait
reporté ou 30 donc vous comprenez tout
de suite que là encore il ya
certainement de flou qui doit être levé
le fait qu'on sait sur quoi exactement
le flux portent essentiellement sur le
collège électoral
alors pour définir le collège électoral
il faut d'abord définir qui est membre
de cette association
ensuite qui aimant à jour de ses
cotisations si marino date ça c'est le
boulot dans la mire watts
tout à fait ouais tout à fait et ce
qu'il a fait aux poudres lors de
l'assemblée générale du 7 septembre
exactement parce que j'avais reçu le
collège électoral par mille moins d'une
demi-heure avant l'assemblée générale
est aujourd'hui à l'heure où je vous
parle nous avons nous n'avons toujours
aucune connaissance de la liste adverse
à savoir si les 22 noms qui avaient qui
portait qui avait créé le différencie
ces 22 n'ont été réintroduit au passage
aujourd'hui
ne savait pas aujourd'hui ne le savons
pas mais nous ne connaissons pas non
plus la liste des candidats adverses
donc nous ne savons même pas contre qui
nous allons nous présenter en assemblée
générale eh bien puisque vous parlez de
la liste adverse la vôtre c'est qui la
nôtre sera connue le moment voulu et
nous sommes donc pas parler en langues
et transparence lionel da rocha en tout
cas si alice initial fait de mal j'ai
avec lionel dire aux aubes ablement
aussi une carrière ça c'est vous qui le
dites mais je ne les vois je ne dis pas
je vous pose une question non je n'ai
pas peur ce n'est qu'un des noms qui
avaient circulé lors de l'assemblée
générale du 7 septembre puisque vous
pour vous nous prenez le corps et
puisque vous aviez cette information
avant d'arriver dans ce studio et que
vous ne la fait partager la en ce moment
qu'est ce qui va se passer là m il y
aura des tractations avec alain miroiter
ce que vous avez eu des contact
régulièrement avec alain miroite
l'administrateur alors depuis le 7
septembre
je n'ai que contact avec mme et niwat
quand j'ai pris connaissance sur le
quotidien de la tenue de l'assemblée
générale 2,16
je me suis permis de l'appeler et au
risque de vous étonner
il était aussi surpris que moi il était
un outil aussi su ou plus que moi il
m'avait et s'était engagé à collecter
des informations revenir vers moi et
depuis les communications se font
uniquement par un autre conseiller et
votre conseil vaut 10 croient nos
conseils nous dit qu'aujourd'hui
l'assemblée générale a été repoussée au
30 le temps que les flous le teint comme
nous réclamations soit prise en compte
il y avait comme une petite différence
sur la publication de cette annonce
par rapport à celle du du 7 septembre
dans l'ordre du jour il y avait un
chapitre est consacré aux questions
diverses qui avait disparu pour cette
nouvelle convocation est ce que vous par
exemple lionel des roses puisque vous
prônez la transparence certain nombre de
choses au niveau du mime
excusez-moi tendance alfred marie-jeanne
par exemple comme la transparence est ce
que vous demanderiez votre conseil de
faire pression pour que ces questions
diverses apparaissant à l'ordre du jour
de cette nouvelle assemblée générale qui
se tiendra le 30
vous savez l'administrateur si m me what
on a bien compris qu'il avait un certain
nombre de difficultés à tenir cette
assemblée générale dans les règles de
l'art donc pourquoi il a supprimé les
questions diverses ne sais pas
maintenant nous sommes prêts à répondre
à toutes les questions
oui il ya aucune question viril fouet
les conseils des deux parties pourraient
s'entendre et demandé alain miroite par
exemple que cette question revienne tout
à fait je ne n'y voit pas d'objection
on y voyait pas d'objection vous avez lu
lé constat le procès verbal de constat
d'huissier qui était là le 7 septembre
non je n'ai pas eu besoin de le lire
alors vous le fera pas revenir en tout
cas ce qu'il dit ce qui est dit dans ce
procès verbal c'est que la
responsabilité de là j'ai avorté du 7
septembre
combet principalement à votre temps ce
sont ses propos se sont il prend ses
responsabilités maintenant il faudrait
qu'ils puissent nous expliquer pourquoi
ça incomber à notre camp mais si vous
étiez présent vous avez alors que
j'étais présent je vous avez en tout cas
au maroc et que j'ai dû mettre en place
une organisation pour faire maintenir ou
à quitter les lieux le vent sous une
pluie d'insultés de mépris de la partie
adverse alors ya eu beaucoup de
compréhension tout à l'heure vous avez
adresser vos voeux à la population
martiniquaise vous aurait pu ajouter que
de sérénité un peu de séries timide et
de sérénité sur cette île fort charmant
que la martinique est ce que par exemple
quelque chose a été fait au niveau de
votre camp pour qu' il y ait moins de
tensions pour cette assemblée générale à
venir alors même si la date est reporté
aujourd'hui vous avez vu que vous venez
de dire quoi vous et il y avait près de
300 militants qui étaient venus
supporter alfred marie jeanne
vous croyez qu'il est évident de leur
demander de rester très calme très
serein lorsque leurs droits sont bafoués
lorsque le la et la manière n'y est pas
lorsqu on flaire un guet-apens d'un
guet-apens
oui quand on vous communique un collège
électoral 28 minutes avant l'heure de
l'assemblée
quand jusqu'à aujourd'hui quelques mois
après cette date prévue de l'assemblée
générale vous n'avez toujours pas
connaissance de la liste adverse
donc s'il y a des ordres cela incombe
uniquement l'administrateur selon vous
en tout cas à l'organisation aux modes
d'organisation de l'assemblée générale
du débrief donc il n'y aura pas de nos
travail particulier fait de la part de
votre temps pour demander aux
sympathisants aux supporters d'alfred
marie-jeanne peut-être d'y aller mais de
façon un petit peu plus tranquille le
travail qui doit être fait c'est de
demander à l'administrateur de prendre
toutes les dispositions pour que les
droits de chacun soit respecté et tout
se passera dans comme s'il doit avoir
semblé génial on attendra donc cette
date du 30 du 30 janvier si elle est
confirmée une question quand même par
rapport à cette réunion qu'il a eue au
gros morne à la fin du mois d'août
quelques jours avant la date prévue de
la première assemblée générale du 7
septembre
dans le cas où cette assemblée générale
du 30 janvier abouti à une victoire de
la liste adverse
est ce qu'on pourrait considérer que
cette assemblée générale du gros morne
avec alfred marie-jeanne serait une
sorte d'assemblée générale constitutive
d'une nouvelle formation politique
une nouvelle fois je voulais une
question je vous pose la question le
mythe politique existe existera toujours
jusqu'à ce que les militants décident de
changer de président
le président étant alfred marie jeanne
ils l'ont prouvé aux gones d'alfred
marie jeanne avait tout le soutien des
militants et sympathisants eh bien il
n'y a pas lieu de créer un autre parti
politique le parti politique existe son
président c'est alfred marie-jeanne
l'association me mme szili assemblée
générale et si il y à ce qu'on pourrait
appeler victoire des facs sioniste parce
que sa venue domine vraiment pourquoi il
y aller si vous rejetez cette
organisation si vous rejetez l'esprit
même de cette assemblée générale
pourquoi vous y allez finalement si vous
n'avez rien à faire pourquoi vous y
allez il faut comprendre deux choses en
20 secondes deux choses la première il y
une volonté manifeste des 41 fait manger
du monde politique pour faire place à
une autre équipe qui se prépare déjà à
prendre l'assemblée générale à prendre
la collectivité territoriale demandé ni
vous parlez de jean philippe et annie
laure qui annonce la création de son
mouvement le 3 février aubert a proposé
pour la question il avait annoncé
janvier pourquoi il ne l'a fait pas en
janvier et en février
simplement pour attendre son verdict au
lendemain de l'assemblée générale voilà
--et voilà donc le temps de démolir le
mime pour qu'il puisse crier ce nouveau
braquage
merci lionel des roses merci d'avoir été
ce matin avec nous dans son crédit bonne
journée à vous c'est moi qui vous
remercie